[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten haben
die zahl der korona toten in deutschland
gibt es seit heute über
100.000 dazu kommen wir im verlaufe der
sendung noch lippen jetzt aber erst mal
nach berlin wie sich dort vor dem
hintergrund der gesundheitskrise die
neue regierung formt wie immer kommen
die personalentscheidungen zum schluss
und das kann manchmal schwieriger sein
als die inhalte zumal es in einer
dreier-koalition pro pattaya weniger
posten zu verteilen gibt und dabei so
viel zu bedenken ist die ministerinnen
und minister sollen ja auch
unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche
regionale und parteiinterne gruppen
repräsentieren bei den grünen war
darüber ein ziemlicher kampf
ausgebrochen berichtet klaus brodbeck es
geht natürlich ums programm genau das
was es davon in den koalitionsvertrag
geschafft hat nach der gefühlt grünen
weiten enttäuschung über dürre sätze
noch nach der sondierung ist mut machen
gefragt wir starben möglicherweise
diese regierung in der schwersten
gesundheitskrise die deutschland jemals
hatte ich glaube es lohnt sich einfach
genau hin zu gucken was in diesem
ergebnis alles drinsteckt und es wird
wahnsinnig viel arbeit werden es wird
eine echte herausforderung für uns
werden doch es geht natürlich auch ums
personal weniger um die beiden um die
sich sonst bei den grünen beinahe alle
street es geht um die dahinter und so
harmonisch die grünen sich auf der bühne
auch geben hinter den kulissen tobt der
streit wer kriegt wer wird was welche
personen von welchem flügel der partei
das spannendste an der liste fürs
kabinett sind die lücken des olaf scholz
kanzler wird keine überraschung mehr
dass robert habeck wirtschafts und
klimaschutzminister und annalena
baerbock außenministerin werden sollen
ziemlich sicher doch um drei weitere
grüne ministerien ringen vier bewerber
mindestens darunter zu wenig linke zu
viele real los da ist es wieder das alte
problem begrünen einzig die fdp hat
schon alles geklärt christian lindner
übernimmt das finanz volker wissing
marko buschmann und bettina stark
watzinger verkehrs justiz und
bildungsministerium bei der spd hubertus
heil seinen posten verteidigen zu können
um für weitere ministerien aber wird
parteiintern auch hier noch gepokert
doch wohl kaum so erbittert wie im
moment bei den grünen fraktionschef
anton hofreiter promovierter biologe
sahen parteilinke sicher im
landwirtschaftsministerium
nun muss er darum mit champ erste meer
und den reales kämpfen und die grünen
die präsentation ihre kabinettsliste
hastig auf morgen verschieben mut machen
die zweite wir sind überzeugt das ist
heute auch hier erst der anfang für eine
gute regierung die richtig was verändern
können und zwar wenn wir das gemeinsam
angehen viel zeit bleibt nicht ab morgen
entscheiden die parteimitglieder per
urabstimmung über den koalitionsvertrag
und ihre ministerinnen in der ampel noch
droht der grünen leuchte darin meine art
politischer wackelkontakt
ja aber da tut sich was am abend contra
banerjee das war ein ziemliches ein
stechen bei den grünen aber jetzt gibt
es meldungen dass es eine einigung gibt
ja tatsächlich hat kam vor wenigen
minuten die information dass das problem
gelöst sei um das sich heute abend der
streit gedreht hat und die
und die künftigen kabinettsmitglieder
der grünen bekannt gegeben worden sind
michael kellner hat eine e mail an die
parteimitglieder geschrieben die uns
auch vorliegt und darin sind die namen
deutlich benannt annalena baerbock
tatsächlich das außenministerium robert
habeck bekommt das superministerium
klima und wirtschaft steffi lemke das
umweltministerium und der umstrittenen
posten landwirtschaft er geht
tatsächlich an cem özdemir anton
hofreiter geht leer aus und damit hat er
mir also den den kollegen vom linken
flügel ausgestochen dafür gibt es einen
ersatz und zwar für das
familienministerium einen spiegel aus
rheinland pfalz die auch zum linken
flügel gehört und kulturstaatsministerin
wird claudia roth so steht es in dieser
e-mail also das problem ist fürs erste
gelöst aber diesen sauberen start den
die grünen sich vorgestellt hatten in
die neue amt regierung den hat der
streit ordentlich verhagelt
hinterlässt enttäuschte und verletzte
schauen wir noch kurz zur spd die lässt
sich ja noch zeit mit ihrem personal
tableau ja und zwar ordentlich und das
obwohl es von mehreren seiten drängen
gibt es doch wenigstens ein neuer
gesundheitsminister oder
gesundheitsministerium benannt wird der
oder die sich möglichst zügig schon mal
um die vorbereitung der nächsten
schritte mit kümmern kann olaf scholz
hat betont er möchte seine neuen
kabinettsmitglieder nicht vor dem
parteitag am vierten dezember benennen
eine offizielle begründung ist dass er
auf jeden fall sicherstellen möchte dass
sein kabinett zu 50 prozent mit frauen
besetzt ist und dafür wollte er eben
abwarten bis bekannt ist wie fdp und
grüne ihre ihre plätze im kabinett
nominieren das ist ja jetzt bekannt er
könnte also eigentlich loslegen aber wie
gesagt das hat er eigentlich nicht vor
und die frage ist warum nicht entweder
möchte er sich mehr zeit lassen und das
ganze besser vorbereitet als die grünen
oder er möchte sich vielleicht auch
größere diskussionen mit den
parteimitgliedern auf dem parteitag
ersparen also beides wäre eine
möglichkeit das ganze etwas geordneter
durchzuführen als ich die grünen heute
vorgemacht haben dank unterland für
diese aktuelle informationen aus berlin
ja stichwort zeit lassen die ampel
koalition will sich jetzt zehn tage zeit
nehmen zitat um die entwicklung der
korona lage zu beobachten bei
exponentiellen wachstum sind zehn tage
eine epidemische ewigkeit heute sind die
gemeldeten neuinfektionen bereits auf
fast
76.000 geklettert und es gibt
351 neue todesfälle das sind menschen
die sich vor zwei drei oder vier wochen
infizierten da waren die
infektionszahlen noch niedriger
modellierer befürchten sollten die 2g
und 3g maßnahmen nicht die gewünschte
bremswirkung erzielen dann könnten wir
in zehn tagen sogar 100.000
neuinfektionen täglich haben und daraus
folgend um weihnachten herum gar 800
tote pro tag
die gesundheitsminister der länder rufen
nun dazu auf das bundesweit planbare
operationen verschoben werden zur krone
lage annegret oster
es ist der letzte ausweg von suhl wird
diese kurve patienten nach hannover
geflogen in niedersachsen gibt es noch
betten die thüringen nicht mehr hat ein
drittel aller intensivpatienten hier
haben korrekt die notfallreserve an
betten wird immer enger wir sind
wirklich in einem tiefroten bereich es
wird eng damit wir notfallpatienten
nicht nur patienten sondern auch andere
notfall patienten versorgen können wir
kratzen tatsächlich an der
katastrophensituation
verlegt wird nach dem kleeblatt konzept
deutschland ist dafür in fünf regionen
unterteilt wenn im eigenen verbund kein
platz mehr ist nehmen die anderen auf
aus bayern und den östlichen
bundesländern werden rund 80 verlegungen
konkret geplant dass diese patienten die
ja intensiv sich also schwer krank sind
durch den transport keinen zusätzlichen
schaden nehmen aus diesem grunde achten
wir besonders darauf dass wir
stabilisierte patienten also stabile
patienten verlegen und dafür gibt es
kriterien die auf die warten und
situationen aber auch die kreis auf
situation abspielen um durch das
transport geschehen kein schaden den
patienten zuzufügen auch in sachsen sind
die intensivstationen am anschlag die
sieben tage incidents ist seit heute
vierstellig sie liegt bei 1.000
74,6 die bundesweit höchste instanz bei
der bundesweit niedrigsten im quote
liegt deutlich unter 60 prozent
die beschlossenen maßnahmen wie shoppen
und restaurantbesuch nur für genesene
und geimpfte und nächtliche
ausgangssperren für ungeimpfte all das
reicht längst nicht aus
deswegen wissen müssen wir uns mit
berlin als benehmen setzen welche
möglichkeiten wir noch haben um
tatsächlich vor allem das thema
begegnung was man also kontakte hat dass
wir das herunterfahren können welche
maßnahmen favorisieren sie dann den lock
down oder gibt es andere varianten also
jeder der eine andere variante weiß kann
die mir nennen ich sehe im moment keine
andere variante diese variante hätte
sachsen durchaus früher verhängen können
jetzt geht das nicht mehr das neu
beschlossene
infektionsschutzgesetz verbietet seit
heute landesweite lockdown
viel mehr impfungen der einzige weg raus
aus der pandemie in der
strukturschwachen altmark in sachsen
anhalt setzen sie auf mobile im teams
räumliche nähe hilft hier fielen bei der
impfentscheidung genau sonst hätte ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht weil
ich gerade spazieren gegangen bin und
darum habe ich gesagt dann kann ich mich
stellen also derzeit haben wir wirklich
seit einiger seit einigen wochen diesen
trend nach oben ganz eindeutig und bis
jetzt können wir eigentlich nicht
feststellen dass der gebrochen ist der
druck sich impfen zu lassen nehme immer
mehr zu sagen hier viele
sich jeden tag testen zu lassen ist
aufwendiger als die impfung gut finden
sie es nicht aber man schickt sich halt
in das unvermeidliche
weil mein arbeitgeber mich dazu zu sagen
verpflichtet hat sonst darf mich nicht
mehr weiterbeschäftigen und jetzt ohne
den arbeitgeber würden sie sich nicht
impfen lassen
manchmal hilft fakten schaffen eben mehr
als alle überzeugungsarbeit
am abend landete der helikopter mit der
kogit patientin aus suhl in hannover es
werden noch viele flüge quer durch
deutschland folgen im kampf um
menschenleben
zur krone lage und speziell der
verlegung von intensivpatienten gibt es
nachher im heute-journal update noch ein
expertengespräch mit dem
notfallmediziner jan thorsten grützner
derweil häufen sich in den stark
betroffenen regionen die
schulschließungen in sachsen etwa sind
aktuell mehr als 300 schulen wegen zu
vieler corona fälle ganz oder teilweise
geschlossen das ist eigentlich auch
nicht verwunderlich für kinder unter
zwölf gab es bisher noch gar keinen
impfstoff zulassung zugleich begeben sie
sich täglich in klassische infektions
situation viele menschen in
geschlossenen räumen dennoch wird in
einigen bundesländern weiterhin auf das
maske tragen im klassenzimmer verzichtet
die nordrhein westfälische
schulministerin beispielsweise geht
davon aus dass regelmäßiges testen
genügt und schulen wie zitat hygiene
filter wirken eltern die an der hygiene
filter theorie zweifel haben denken
vielleicht eher ans impfen die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde hat
heute jedenfalls die zulassung des
ersten impfstoffes für kinder unter
zwölf empfohlen susanne gelhard
berichtet
in den usa in superman persönlich die
fünf- bis elfjährigen seit anfang
november schon auch in israel und kanada
gibt es bereits grünes licht und heute
auch für die eu durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde die ständige
impfkommission des robert-koch-instituts
will bis ende dezember ihre empfehlung
für deutschland aussprechen ich gehe
sicher davon aus dass eine mindest
empfehlung für die risikokinder
ausgesprochen wird weil es da deutlich
erhöhte risiken gibt durch ko wird 19
auch in dieser altersklasse von fünf bis
elf jahren schwer zu erkranken aber
insgesamt ist wichtig dass diese
altersgruppe von allen altersgruppen in
deutschland diejenige ist die zwar viele
infektionen aber die niedrigste
krankheitslast hat
eine impfung für kinder die weniger
schwer erkranken als erwachsene wie groß
ist der nutzen wie hoch die risiken laut
zulassungsstudie zeigt der impfstoff bei
fünf bis elfjährigen eine wirksamkeit
von 90,7 prozent und ist gut verträglich
er hat dieselbe zusammensetzung wie der
für erwachsene
die dosierung ist jedoch nur ein drittel
so hoch also statt 30 nur zehn
mikrogramm im klinikum itzehoe bekommt
kinderarzt dr hillebrand bereits jetzt
viele anfragen von eltern die ihre
kinder impfen lassen wollen er meint der
nutzen einer impfung überwiege die
risiken möglicher nebenwirkungen denn
auch bei kindern könne es schwere
krankheitsverläufe geben die kollegen in
amerika die ja die impfung eindeutig
empfehlen haben inzwischen über drei
millionen kinder kämpft das heißt also
täglich wächst die datenbasis auf die
wir blicken können auch in bezug auf
sicherheit der impfung und das wird
natürlich die stiko auch nutzen
viele eltern warten jetzt auf die
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
sie will mit mehr daten auch seltenere
nebenwirkungen untersuchen für mütter
und väter eine entscheidungshilfe
ich selber bin geimpft und bin da
eigentlich auch eher
positiv eingestellt und denke dass ich
mir dann nach eingehender prüfung und
der beratung durch die kinderärzte auch
ein entsprechendes bild machen werde wir
werden unser kind unsere ältere tochter
auf jeden fall
impfen lassen sobald es geht ich wollte
diese stiko meldung abwarten weil ich
denke wenn man schon so eine kommission
hat dann möchte ich die auch
nehmen und wissen was die was sie davon
denken in vier wochen sollen auch für
die jüngsten impflinge in deutschland
die ersten 24 millionen dosen impfstoff
zur verfügung stehen
und jetzt machen erstmal gundela weiter
mit anderen nachrichten des tages
wieder sind dutzende migranten mit
kleinen booten über den ärmelkanal an
die küste großbritanniens gelangt sie
hatten sich auf den weg gemacht trotz
der tragödie gestern bei der 27 menschen
ihr leben verloren frankreich und
großbritannien streiten über die schuld
an den illegalen überfahrten fünf
mutmaßliche menschenschmuggler wurden in
frankreich festgenommen darunter ein
verdächtiger aus deutschland für sonntag
hat paris mehrere für migration
zuständige minister aus der eu
eingeladen um die anstrengungen europas
zu koordinieren drei monate nach dem
abzug internationaler truppen aus
afghanistan harren dort noch
2400 aktive und ehemalige ortskräfte
deutscher institutionen aus das
bundesinnenministerium erklärte auf
anfrage der linken bis anfang november
seien
456 ortskräfte mit ihren nächsten
angehörigen nach deutschland eingereist
die kritik der linken die
bundesregierung lasse die menschen trotz
zusagen im stich
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg hat die
ampel koalition aufgerufen mehr geld für
die rüstung auszugeben als die
scheidende bundesregierung mit polens
präsident du da sprach stoltenberg über
die ungewöhnlichen russischen truppen
bewegungen an der grenze zur ukraine
sowie über die erdgaspipeline nord
stream 2 duda forderte die
inbetriebnahme zu stoppen sie steigere
das russische gas monopol und sei eine
gefahr für die eu in sibirien sind beim
schwersten grubenunglück seit jahren in
einem kohlebergwerk
52 menschen ums leben gekommen dutzende
wurden verletzt
vergangene nacht war aus noch
ungeklärter ursache unter tage kohle
staub in brand geraten 14 todesopfer
konnten geborgen werden die suche nach
38 vermissten in der tiefe wurde
eingestellt ermittlungen gehen dem
verdacht nach dass
sicherheitsvorschriften nicht
eingehalten wurden helfer teams konnten
239 menschen retten
der konflikt zwischen der eu und
spielerisch geht weiter angela merkel
und polens regierungschef im radio es
gebe sprachen sich dazu heute in berlin
das merkel zwischenzeitlich auch mit dem
belarussischen diktator lukaschenko
telefoniert hatte waren polen zunächst
ja nicht gut angekommen diese
missstimmung sollte heute ausgeräumt
werden beide wiederholten ihre vorwürfe
an belarus menschen für hybride attacken
auf die eu zu missbrauchen derweil im
grenzgebiet zwischen polen und belarus
längst minustemperaturen herrschen das
macht die situation der geflüchteten
immer schlimmer die dort ja regelrecht
gefangen sind angelockt und hin
geschleppt von belarussischen regie
kabul berichtet
an der grenze ist der erste schnee
gefallen das syrische geschwisterpaar
das von freiwilligen helfern aufgespürt
wird hat glück gehabt seit ein paar
tagen schon irren sie durch die
polnischen wälder
wundersamerweise haben wir es hierher
geschafft wir sind selig glücklich hier
zu sein
die beiden kommen aus damaskus sind nach
münster geflogen und haben an der grenze
die brutalität der villa russischen
offiziere erlebt
sie haben uns gezwungen über die
polnische grenze zu gehen sie haben uns
erzählt entweder sterbt ihr in belarus
oder er versucht nach polen
rüberzukommen
fast täglich veröffentlicht der
polnische grenzschutz bilder wie diese
wähler russische soldaten die die polen
mit lasern blenden die
grenzbefestigungen zerstörung in gruppen
von geflüchteten nach polen zu schicken
der polnische ministerpräsident morawetz
gehofft auf europäische unterstützung
und bekommt sie bei seinem besuch in
berlin
mit deshalb einerseits die volle
solidarität zu polen auf der anderen
seite natürlich ganz klar auszudrücken
dass es sich hier um ein thema handel
zwischen der europäischen union und
belarus und dass deshalb natürlich alles
was bilateral geschieht auch eng
abgestimmt werden muss mit branimir
verteidigen die eu-außengrenze also
verteidigen wir deutschland vor einer
großen welle von flüchtlingen vor
ort wo
trauerfeier in bochum niki für ein
wenige tage altes baby einer syrischen
familie
das ist die realität von der die
polnische regierung nicht spricht die
toten die opfer dieses konflikts ums
leben gekommen in den polnischen wälder
tausende schätzen hilfsorganisationen
verstecken sich dort weil sie befürchten
zurück nach belarus geschickt zu werden
polen hat eine sperrzone eingerichtet
journalisten dürfen nicht rein
hilfsorganisationen auch nicht wir haben
zwei forderung die eine ist dass wir
zugang bekommen zu dieser sperrzone und
die zweite forderung ist dass menschen
die möglichkeit bekommen einen
asylantrag zu stellen in polen und dass
diese anträge vernünftig transparent
geprüft werden dann könnten wir glaube
ich die lage hier verbessern in vielen
orten entlang der sperrzone werden
medikamente warme kleider für die
geflüchteten gesammelt einige haben
extra urlaub genommen um zu helfen
ich persönlich glaube dass unsere
regierung schlecht handelt diese zone
das sollte nicht sein egal ob wir
menschen aufnehmen oder sie abweisen
aber die situation in der zone das was
in den wäldern passiert das darf nicht
sein
die geschwister aus syrien werden vom
grenzschutz in empfang genommen
nach dem was wir durchgemacht haben
wollen wir nur einen sicheren platz
holen wäre gut die beiden syrer kommen
in ein auffanglager können in polen asyl
beantragen vielleicht auch weil bei
ihrer rettung kameras mit dabei war
zurück nach deutschland die bildung der
neuen regierung in berlin beschäftigt
auch die wirtschaft und ja der
koalitionsvertrag der neuen
bundesregierung mit seinen folgen für
wirtschaft und finanzen war auch heute
thema an den finanzmärkten
dort schauen die akteure vor allem auf
die frage der finanzierbarkeit der
vorhaben stephanie berit und sehen eben
auch risiken ja die risiken bestehenden
finanziell ambitionierten vorhaben deren
genaue kosten zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch gar nicht genau beziffert werden
können für die aber immense summen
aufgetrieben werden müssen dazu könnte
die neue regierung im nächsten jahr sich
nochmal mit krediten vollsaugen den 20
23 greift so viel steht zumindest fest
wieder die gesetzliche schuldenbremse
allzweckwaffe soll der sogenannte
energie und klimafonds seien in diesem
reservetopf praktisch holz als
finanzminister bereits 26 milliarden
euro noch dieses jahr könnte die neue
koalition in mit mindestens 60
milliarden auf punkten eine umbuchung
aus nicht abgerufenen corona krediten
haushalts experten sehen das durchaus
kritisch wird der korona ausnahmezustand
doch dazu genutzt in diesem jahr mehr
schulden zu machen als eigentlich
notwendig weiteres kapital könnte mit
der höheren verschuldung öffentlicher
unternehmen wie etwa der bahn
mobilisiert werden die staatseigene
förderbank kfw soll stärker eingespannt
werden wie man insgesamt mehr private
investoren ins boot holen will auch das
streichen von subventionen soll geld in
die kassen spülen und am ende steht ein
gigantisches
investitionsprojekt dass deutschland in
eine neue zeit katapultiert klar es
kostet viel geld doch selbst
konservative ökonomen sind froh dass die
probleme mangelnder investitionen in
deutschland nun endlich richtig erkannt
sind eine sicht der dinge vielen dank
stefanie nach frankfurt
in der fußball-europa-league hat bayer
leverkusen celtic glasgow mit 3 zu 2
besiegt und sich damit für das
achtelfinale
qualifiziert und in der konferenz league
gewann union berlin sein gruppenspiel
auswärts gegen den israelischen meister
maccabi haifa 1 0 in dem festgefahrenen
tarifkonflikt des öffentlichen dienstes
der länder fordert verdi chef wernicke
kurz vor der dritten verhandlungsrunde
einen deutlichen lohnzuwachs um 5
prozent erneut beteiligten sich
bundesweit tausende
gewerkschaftsmitglieder an warnstreiks
insbesondere das engagement der
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen wird
laut verdi zu wenig gewürdigt die
gehälter von pflegekräften sollten um
300 euro pro monat angehoben werden
möchte man vier männern acht stunden
lang dabei zu sehen und zu hören wie sie
miteinander ringen teils genervt und
auch erschöpft ja möchte man wenn es
sich um die beatles hunted anfang 1969
sperrten sie sich für einige wochen
regelrecht einen einen studio workshop
der zugleich eine art selbsthilfe
seminar war die beziehungen
untereinander waren schwierig geworden
ein gemeinsames konzert hatte es schon
lange nicht mehr gegeben die zukunft der
beatles stand auf der kippe ein neues
album sollte eingespielt werden und
dabei ließen die vier sich von einem
kamerateam begleiten so entstand damals
tonnenweise filmmaterial das jetzt in
einer dreiteiligen doku serie
veröffentlicht wird aus london und reas
statt
[Musik]
gute laune jede menge spaß die aufnahmen
zum finalen beatles album let it be
1969 in einem londoner filmstudio lassen
die fed vor die kamera stundenlang mit
laufen für eine doku die 1970 er version
zeigt eine mehr oder weniger
streitlustige band die dabei ist zu
zerfallen übrig bleiben 60 stunden
ungenutztes material der schatz feld
hollywood regisseur peter jackson in die
hände einem wahren beatles fan ich hätte
es nicht gemacht bei den rolling stones
aber den beatles jahr mit haut und haar
vier jahre ich habe jede sekunde geliebt
so lange wird man sich jackson dem
material die aufwändige technische
bearbeitung inklusive was es wert war so
der star regisseur weil die ungenutzten
szenen zumindest ein teil der beatles
geschichtsschreibung infrage stellen
[Musik]
wenn er das material eine band in einem
erbärmlichen zustand gezeigt hätte die
keine lust auf musik machen mehr hatte
ich hätte es nicht gemacht einen solchen
film niemals aber ich war überrascht und
beeindruckt das ist eine ganz andere
geschichte erzählte als die an die ich
40 jahre geglaubt habe
[Musik]
die doku get back drei teile acht
stunden nie zuvor gezeigt das material
auf den dann auch die dunklen wolken am
horizont zu sehen sind zu große egos mit
anderen musikalischen wie geschäftlichen
vorstellungen doch selbst eingefleischte
fans dürften neues erfahren bis hin zum
plan der beatles herr der ringe zu
verfilmen
ich habe paul mccartney dazu quasi
verhört am ende konnten sie die rechte
von tolkien nicht bekommen da die idee
nicht mochte dass eine popband sein werk
umsetzt
das übernahm dann jackson der nicht mehr
verrät aber durch neue technische
verfahren konnten gespräche zwischen den
bandmitgliedern hörbar gemacht werden
die im probenraum untergegangen waren
die beatles noch einmal zum letzten mal
ein spaß viele einsichten nicht nur für
fans
weimar ist es gleich weiter mit dem
thema der woche die ampel und corona zu
gast sind unter anderem robert habeck
und volker wissing und
christopher wehrmann meldet sich um 0.30
mit unserem heute-journal update hier
erwarten sie morgen wunder und claus
kleber einen schönen abend noch auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schön genau zu und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das
wettergeschehen wird demnächst dominiert
von tiefster auf der zugbahn von nord
nach süd kalte luft bringen regen und
auch schnee sie können auch nicht anders
ziehen denn das hoch auf dem atlantik
ist riesig und blockiert den weg der
tiefs ja ein weiteres tief gibt es über
dem mittelmeer oder schiebt von süden
schnee richtung süddeutschland schauen
wir uns das ganze mal im detail an im
süden kommt also schnee auf im laufe der
nacht wird es rutschig einige schauer
gibt es ganz im norden sonst ist es
trocken teilweise bildet sich nebel bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus vier
grad am alpenrand und -2 nach westen
also hier ziemlich kalt ansonsten in der
mitte um null grad frostfrei mit zwei
bis vier grad an den küsten morgen
weiterer schneefall im südosten und
weiterhin auf straßenglätte sonst kommt
auch schnee in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen auf der fällt bis 300
meter herab und darunter ist es regen
auch nach norden hin ansonsten
dominieren viele wolken temperaturen
dazu erreichen höchstwerte minus 1 grad
ganz im süden unter fünf bis sechs grad
ganz im norden deutschlands schnee
bleibt ein thema in den nächsten tagen
und fällt dann auch sogar bis ins
flachland runter zum beispiel im westen
und auch im süden bei 1 bis 5 grad am
samstag und ja darauf die tage weitere
schneefälle bei minus ein bis fünf grad
damit ein schöner abend